it is that leading companies frontrunner
comments the company's as we already
already have seen take the lead and
demonstrate that this is a way for a lot
so I think the pass will be the good
examples the front-runner examples and
then we have a lot of follow-ups when
they really understand that on all
levels you know or to all stakeholders
being your customers your employees
politicians media public in general that
this is the way to to develop a company
then the rest will be will be easy
% you have to adopt all kinds of
strategies especially to to ensure the
follow-ups follow up fast and firm
besides that we need to create a much
stronger knowledgebase related document
where do we benefit where do we have the
prior years and that means that a strong
strong focus on R&D will be important so
we developed strong cases strong
material strong knowledge about these
issues
you can always discuss that and not a
lot of people could discuss that of
course they have no assault
responsibility to document benefits of
sustainability but I don't think you
have to ask them to do that and you
don't have to don't have to provoke them
to do that because they do it naturally
the companies who really see this is a
part an important part of their brand
porn part of the business strategy
important part of the whole recent data
they will have a natural interest in
telling the good stories and spectacle
stores spider good news so application
RINs possibility or not they'll do it by
themselves and their natural drive for
doing so so we don't have to force it
upon them it will come based on a market
drive market interest so I'm quite
confident that I automatically will set
the standard
they can do it if they want so big
they have a strong power they have
strong networks they have the
communication skills and so they can
change it overnight they can set a
standard overnight if they if they want
so so a bed has pointed out they'll do
it and they can do it and there are good
communicators they know how to sell a
product and if the product what it is
here is just an ability they'll do it
they can do it and no doubt they'll have
a huge impact when they do it
it is really to to make a sustained a
business that's their way of being
sustainable they've been sustainable if
they tell about their sustainable
strategies all companies have a natural
interest in having a strong position to
the stake holes again being the
employees it will be very important part
of their of the of the ability to
attract new talent that you ask the
Salem company who wants to work for a
non-sustainable company but it's a
burden in a way to influence political
decisions the public in general the
media's whatever so they have a strong
natural interest in being planting he
planted in being positioned as social as
sustainable companies who really wants
not just to be best in the world but
best for the world
reluctant be
they feel wrongly that it could hurt
their business that it will spoil their
markets if sustainability gets to be a
widespread trend but they're very wrong
it's a very short side of you you are
fighting a lost case and they are
fighting a lost case they have to
understand too that the basic trend in
society equals sustainability and who
you can't argue against sustainability
and fighting for solving climate change
problems so but but from a short side
view they fear it could damage the
business they fear that their
stakeholders would be scared and all
these things very short-sighted but they
learn they will run late and they are
paid for being late movers but they'll
learn and i'm quite sure they have to
understand to what is ahead